I knew you just went in and interviewed
Alex Jones and I had to sit down with
Alex Jones yeah what was that kind of
like was that do you think the guy was
absolutely crazy do you think he was
overwhelmed by the the lawsuit at this
point
um or do you feel like he's on point
with some stuff and he's just too loud
for the world these days like
I don't know it's such a tough one
because I I do see both angles of it you
know what I mean I had a lot of heat
from a lot of my fans for even talking
to him
I mean the billion dollar verdict it's
he probably has between two and three
million dollars and Infowars or Free
Speech systems is filing for bankruptcy
so he's not gonna the the Sandy Hook
families aren't going to see that money
right but um I guess it's a precedent in
the future for it's like if you because
he was really coming after the parents
as well right you know like he put one
of the parents addresses up it's
egregious I mean it's egregious when
somebody go and I can't imagine when you
go through something like that yeah and
there's this voice that gets loud yeah
but I'm reading this book called Sandy
Hook by Elizabeth Elizabeth Williamson
and like some of the dudes that Alex was
like platforming on his [ __ ] I hate
saying platforming but like let's do the
Wolfgang how big and there's people who
like were threatening like 4 000 emails
a day to the Sandy Hook family's like
type [ __ ] like harassing them stalking
them leaving messages saying they're
gonna kill them accusing them of keeping
their kids alive as sex slaves in the
attic and [ __ ] horrible stuff so it
wasn't a lot of people it's not just
about Alex it's just somebody the ripple
effect yeah because there's a home
community of lost people who devote
their whole life to harassing the
victims families of the Colorado Aurora
shooting of Sandy Hook of Uvalde like
it's a whole community of you know
crisis actor followers like false flag
have you been able to meet any of those
types of folks even just to see like
because I think one thing that's really
interesting that you do and I really
like seeing it man is that you kind of
just you go and just kind of listen to
people it's like hey here's what's going
on and I think it's really powerful even
as you say like some of your followers
or or supporters like oh why would you
even give this guy a space but people
would say that too about having Bobby
Kennedy on here why would you give this
guy's face like he's a human being he's
first of all one of the smartest guys
that I know yeah like really interesting
and amazing friend yeah so it's like I
wouldn't not trust him like why wouldn't
I listen and hear what his what his
thoughts are and what's going on I I
just think like the more liberal
audience is like super into uh
de-platforming and they think that like
giving someone a giving a problematic
person a platform is somehow supporting
them and I always refute that like this
if I if it's a lesser-known shitty
person that I'm cherry picking to kind
of dunk on that's [ __ ] up you know if
I'm if I bring some white nationalist
from the you know cuts of Alabama on my
show just to like Grill him and make him
look stupid right I am inadvertently
growing his audience by bringing him on
because the people who watch my [ __ ] and
and even if they agree with me his name
is now out there I've elevated his name
to the top and so people will know his
name they'll go to his website you kind
of increase traffic for that person
right and you create future white
nationalists and vice versa but like
Alex Jones everybody knows who that is
he's a household name the proud boys
everybody knows who that is so when I'm
interviewing people like that that most
of my audience doesn't like I am not
increasing their fame or increasing
their exposure because with or without
me everyone's gonna know who those
people are right Alex Jones is on the
front page of the New York Times the
proud boys are being investigated by the
FBI for January 6. so me interviewing
them I'm not platforming or increasing
Their audience at all but you know if I
was to interview like more or lesser
known
you know Fringe people I wouldn't do
that you know yeah like if you were to
interview like Whitey killer 1200 or you
were to interview like um slave buyer 55
exactly then you would be you know or
yeah but mainstream media like liberal
media does that [ __ ] they find like the
dumbest person they can and they're like
inside the Klu Klux Klan and it's and
it's like some like 300 pound like CSI
Miami Watchers sitting in his chair he's
like why people we're just better at
stuff
and the journalist is like what do you
mean by that how can you say something
like that he was like
you know I'm not doing that [ __ ] man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one